this is the craziest ending of mha
shigaraki stole Deku squirk and now he's
about to literally destroy all of Japan
this is really really bad for deu and
the heroes and I did not see that twist
coming near the end so let's get into it
you guys know how this works if you
enjoy my mha videos you want to see more
in the future leave a quick like and
comment for that YouTube algorithm and
if you want to help this channel reach
the insane Milestone of 2 million
subscribers do me a huge favor and
subscribe right now we are less than 10K
away from 2 million finally this video
will contain mha manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned okay Real Talk the previous
chapter was one of the craziest chapters
in the history of mha as all foran
finally met his end at the hands of
bakugo all foran became a baby and
bakugo has no issues with bullying
babies into submission at the end of the
day as a baby ALR was just too weak to
win against bakugo and so he rewound
himself out of existence and finally
perished in the end all for one went out
sad and as he perished so did all the
stolen Quirk factors that he had
contained inside of him including Hawk's
Quirk Factor the vestage of hawks said
that the stolen quirks going back to
their former owners would be nice but
that's not how it works implying that
The Quirk factors just vanished out of
existence along with all for one now is
this actually true like will Hogs be
quirkless forever or will the heroes
figure something out like Aries Quirk or
something along those lines we'll have
to wait and see I'm sure that a lot of
fans would be upset if Hawks remained
quirkless but we have to remember that
this is a war Arc the final war Arc and
sacrifices are inevitable the last
chapter then also warned us that
shigaraki is very different from all for
one all for one wanted to rule Japan as
a sort of villainous Demon Lord but
shigaraki is actually worse because he
doesn't care about ruling he just wants
to destroy everything including Japan
itself there is a real danger that
shigaraki will turn his awakened Decay
on the Earth itself and start causing
massive earthquakes landslides and wide
spread flooding according to shigaraki
he could destroy all of Japan in barely
a week's time and he could do the job so
thoroughly that no one would ever be
able to rebuild ever again the chapter
ended with the situation getting even
worse for the heroes as shigaraki
actually managed to briefly touch deku's
face and steal one of deku's quirks more
specifically he managed to steal danger
sense The Quirk that belonged to the
fourth one for all user shinomori and
already in the latest chapter shigaraki
is using deku's own former Quirk against
him in battle the new chapter starts off
inside deku's vestage world before
danger sense was stolen with all the
vestages discussing the current life or
death battle between Deku and shigaraki
they realized that they have to put an
end to shigaraki as soon as possible
even shigaraki's own Grandma knows that
this man needs to be stopped by any
means necessary but the big problem
remains shigaraki's super regeneration
now that no one is canceling out his
quirks shigaraki has incredible
regenerative abilities and no matter how
much damage he takes he just recovers
almost instantly but while the vestages
are busy strategizing the unthinkable
happens shigaraki makes contact with
deku's face and in that Split Second we
see shigaraki's hand reaching into the
vestage world and snatching shinomori
the fourth user right out of all for one
as the fourth user tells the others that
he is leaving Deku to them banjo informs
Deku that danger sense has been stolen
shon's vestage is no longer part of one
for all because his quirk Factor was
taken out of one for all and placed
inside of shigaraki all for one the
vestiges are shocked that this could
happen since no one's Quirk had ever
been stolen before no matter how many
times All For One tried to do it the
vestages then realized that shigaraki's
hatred really could be stronger than all
of their Wills combined and that means
that losing danger sense could be just
the beginning it's important to note
that shigaraki didn't steal one for all
itself which was all for one's ultimate
goal deu still has one for all and all
the power that it accumulated over over
the generations so he is not physically
weaker as a result of losing danger
sense that said he did lose his
extremely useful spidey sense and what's
worse shigaraki is already able to use
it against Deku he didn't even have to
take time to master it he can just
instantly use danger sense to warn him
when deku's attacks are coming before
they even land shigaraki tells Deku that
he isuku midoria is the biggest nuisance
because he continues to be stuck in the
past he continues to look at shigaraki
as a human being who can still be
reached and saved but shikari believes
that he has now surpassed Humanity he is
no longer who he was before he is
neither tenko nor the old tomura he is
an awakened God of destruction and
deku's insistence on trying to save him
or spare him in anyway is just plain
frustrating as shigaraki attacks Deku
the hero turns himself into a ball by
wrapping himself in multiple layers of
black whip this prevents shigaraki from
making direct contact with deu and in
turn this saves deku's life and his
other quirks from being stolen however
deku's hero mask is now gone destroyed
during the deadly battle against
shigaraki so now he will be squaring off
against shigaraki face to face no more
masks for either of them symbolic or
otherwise and that is when Deku realizes
that shigaraki just lured him to a very
specific place they are now located
right at the foot of Mount Fuji the
tallest and most iconic mountain in
Japan one of the holiest locations in
the country oh and it also just happens
to be an actual freaking volcano you
know what that means right shigaraki can
use the Kay on the ground to destroy
Mount Fuji which would not only be a
devastating blow to Japan symbolically
and culturally but the destruction of
this mountain would also unleash lava
everywhere essentially destroying
everything in sight this chapter makes
it very clear that shigaraki is no
longer all for one's successor he is an
entirely different type of villain and
for shigaraki there are No Boundaries or
limits there is no such thing as Mercy
he doesn't care about building anything
ruling anything controlling anything he
just wants to destroy and that means
that everyone and everything in Japan is
in immediate danger oh and also the
second user Bruce mentioned that deku's
gear shift is running out but they've
been saying that so long that I can't
even take it seriously anymore Deku has
apparently been overusing gear shift for
who knows how many chapters and yet he
still just keeps going as the vestages
discuss how even a single additional
touch from shigaraki could result in all
of One for All and every Quirk Factor
being stolen shigaraki addresses the
vestages directly either because of all
for one's connection to one for all or
because he just stole one of one for
all's quirks but shigaraki is able to
see the vestages and he mocks them he
says that there's no use of them trying
to run away because there will be no
place left to run he will destroy
everything around him and the Cowardly
vestages of one for all who have gotten
stronger by constantly running away and
accumulating more power over time will
finally be destroyed and they will be
able to run no more shigaraki begins to
activate a massive earthquake behind him
and he is planning to spread the
destruction to Mount Fuji and everything
around it but in spite of all of this in
spite of shigaraki now being less human
and more just pure destruction incarnate
Deku refuses to accept that narrative as
his right Gauntlet begins to crack and
crumble deu declares that shigaraki is
human after all even after all of this
and even after shigaraki openly declared
his desire to mercilessly destroy all of
Japan and everyone in it Deku still
wants to see the humanity in shigaraki
he still wants to reach out to little
tenos shimura even as the grown man
standing before him openly tells him
that Teno shimura no longer exists and
this is and always has been deku's
biggest weakness even when shigaraki's
own grandmother is telling Deku that he
may not be able to save shigaraki Deku
still insists on finding little ten
koshimura in there somewhere and a part
of me thinks that H Koshi is emphasizing
this part because he does plan on having
Deku get through to tenko somehow and
save shigaraki but another part of me
thinks that this attitude will be deku's
downfall shigaraki has made it very
clear both with his words and his
actions that he has no interest in being
saved and that he wants to destroy
everything and everyone if Deku really
wants to save the innocent people of
Japan he may have to kill shigaraki at a
certain point it's either shigaraki or
like millions of innocent people there's
no middle ground and sometimes a true
hero has to be willing to make the
difficult decision to do something that
he would rather not do for the greater
good I do hope that Deku figures this
out in time and that he won't end up
making the kind of mistake Goku would
make in a fight against Frieza on Namek
if a single innocent person dies because
Deku hesitated to put an end to
shigaraki when he had the chance how is
he going to live with that fact for all
of deku's many powers and abilities this
really is his major weak point but
speaking of weaknesses could shigaraki's
decision to steal danger sense actually
turn into his own greatest weakness we
know that vages of stolen quirks do have
the ability to rebel against the person
who stole them on the inside because we
saw something like that happen with the
original all for one so if shigaraki
continues stealing The Quirk factors of
the other one for all users could he
actually be filling his own body with a
bunch of deadly Trojan horses is this
how shigaraki will end up getting
defeated by getting too greedy trying to
steal all of One for All quirks and then
getting devoured by the vestages from
the inside well either that or shigaraki
is about to end mha in the darkest way
possible by destroying all of Japan as
the heroes look on helplessly just like
the last chapter this chapter was
absolutely crazy but what's even crazier
is my video about how deu could have
become the final villain in mha check it
out right now link on screen and in the
description